matter of fact let's let's just jump on
like to this okay all right
the breath yep you know the breath the
diaphragm when you breathe
in this girl and this breathing acting
technique okay is like a situation where
you know
the the more breath you have the more
emotion you can bring out
so like let me give you an example okay
i'm gonna use a phrase here
and it's like i'm gonna take a breath
hey man you better give me my damn money
oh man i like that one that's good
see the breath make it make it come off
like it's believable because it's like a
situation where you don't
i'm breathing and i'm like i'm gonna
kick your ass you don't give me my money
okay i like that
okay
hey man give me my money okay see mine
is connected man it's strong
okay it's like hey man you better give
me my damn money how do you get how do
you get that
i'm coming from here from here okay hey
man
you been giving my damn money man
take a breath let me take a breath okay
take a breath in in the stomach okay now
let it come out and say it on the letter
on the bread coming out
okay hey man you better give my damn
money that's it
um that's it oh good let me kind of
watch you gonna get hey man you better
give my damn
money
your ass if i don't get that damn money
you got to put this okay
okay i'm gonna kick your ass and follow
up
hold on i take a little look controlling
me sir
um you right to get the breath take her
no no
remember the boy that was at ucla they
got tased i don't think i remember that
though remember that
oh don't you remember the line he says
oh don't tase me bro
don't you remember that when they
arrested his ass he said don't take it
if you look at that see you can find you
can find such reality as such
real okay
so that boy was real okay he was on
camera and everybody tastes about the
context
is it okay okay another question i'm
gonna show you another one
okay don't
tease me bro okay all right oh
don't taste me bro i got it you ain't
catching that
you'll get canceled because that's from
that's from real experience getting
tased you got changes i got tased my boy
we were drunk we were high and then he
tased me that's what said see
i knew something was like that oh no
together with some real dogs
take that breath okay okay now imagine
this okay
all right all right i'm the cop okay
okay so now what i'm gonna do is
i'm gonna say something to you okay and
you just be in the scene okay take your
breath
okay do you want me to say something
what you want to do i just want you to
sit in line
all right okay all right okay so yeah
you know i was kidding
don't explain nothing all right just
take your breath okay
okay don't chase me bro i'm changing bro
that was not great that was like
commercial right there man there was no
commercial that was a film man i thought
that was because i'm a little
more commercial don't the taser product
is brought to you by
cvs you know like i just okay
well crazy i just want because i'm
saying with that
[ __ ] you know this one okay you know i
love commercials too man because that's
why you love commercials
i go out for commercials well well we
need something look at the teeth
the product is brushing you by be quiet
be quiet you got to listen now
okay there we go you got good technique
and everything okay
you can also when you take that deep
breath you can also get this like now
watch this
oh [ __ ] they bout to evict my ass
oh man i'm good with that one i know try
that out
okay now do i open up a paper or like
pad to my mind no you don't do that just
okay here we go oh [ __ ]
yes
stop just for a second
for a minute but because i haven't been
trying to help because that's where i
have to pause down and then they want me
to put the blossom
because i didn't want to wait no he was
like that way he was like
no he was not though
oh [ __ ]
yeah okay just but you know what you
know what all right can we just do
another phrase inside that one because
that one is that one is two that hits
too close to home there you go again but
that one hits too close to home i don't
wanna let's not talk about that what
let's not
let's let's go like he had a hammer with
his picture notice he's snailing on
there
we're just about to let's let's go let's
go with another phrase because that was
he probably wouldn't nail it or no
that's a nice door he probably he would
he would tape it off
you know there's rules and regulations
and [ __ ] with all these apartment
buildings
and i'm gonna tell you something that's
some [ __ ] man
when they start talking about and when
they start talking about uh
when they start talking about uh we want
to show you a part but don't ever let
them show your data
no no i have one time he tried to show
me come in here man you been
trying to show my apartment wow you mean
you know with your girl faking them